rum mary did you know how easy it is to
make an MMO supposedly it's just not
difficult at all go far off by Ted pile
of goats I'm not dead there's a CH and
the bottom left there as you can see and
it's it's poppin so let oh I mean did
you die that's not gonna get old all
right how do I talk to Greta got a
cousin who's in some deep [ __ ] humans
who I'm just no good oh oh oh killed
myself all right all right all right huh
here we go come with us yeah oh there's
the sim so you can tell by the look on
his face oh you got here hey I've been
stuck in two days just pile of dog [ __ ]
he's gonna eat it to survive how do I
get him out maybe I'll lick it oh you
did oh that is girl is this [ __ ] to my
inventory oh my god oh I think I'm gonna
kill him I received one piece of [ __ ]
fresh fruit get your fruit here oh [ __ ]
your fruit Teen Wolf I'll help you
oh no wait all right Johnny kind of want
to look at my face well your eyes are
all weird hey good helping it's not
right now could you go fetch me some
things first off I need a package of
butter I just like cows so far I've seen
just this one dance move and it's
probably the lamest dance move ever
they've really done a great job of
capturing the essence of what makes a
good mmm oh my shoes are 60 you have not
talked about how amazing your shoes are
this is what it looks like when I swim
sorry dude sorry k come all right let's
try some 000 c coming after me now
you're on fire oh no I'm on fire Oh
couldn't you even you don't even have
like 0 health or anything like I
shouldn't ok sir ok when you put it out
admitted it looks like a hamster wheel
sprint isn't it like maybe it's a
training facility look at this I'm in a
a minute wait what's happening oh no oh
no oh no ma'am i fell out Thank she is
standing on the table yeah oh I'm so
cool I jump I hate got on my way did you
think I cash food is on top now should I
give that guy some [ __ ] see what he does
drop item one
Oh Marcie I didn't yeah where do you run
to hey probably in circles oh I think
you just killed him so whoa you got 10
XP at it that was really dark is he okay
this chat is so good does anyone want to
marry me hey you should join my guild
the Sheep quest is pretty hard though it
is best we're stuck on this guy's whoa
crawling it hey josh its Josh she's like
a Roomba she's just hitting wrongs and
moving or slightly well I think I was
terrifying oh it was weird looking
what's he doing the worm chicken oh gosh
this is weird the dream about this
tonight there they go there Beckham o.o
butter Oh butter what did he oh yeah we
did want butter are you all right how do
I oh don't lose it they butter to
inventory I'm the Magic Man I'll make it
rain card mm-hmm when y'all sorry ass I
can't gain 10 XP or what's running i
think i got it for like jumping oh nice
move thanks um i have leveled up really
fast this is the horse that kills
himself oh oh what's baby deficit kills
himself every she's not here but oh my
god water for fall I mysterious uh-huh
someone just fell off oh look there's a
guy out there I was a bully he probably
threw that person off huh what's up nerd
he was he died oh he wasn't diving water
betting me yeah you bet you eat so did
you just jump off that's why the other
dude jumped off you just jump off there
do it
I'm so cool here for you know from
flopping going up to that boy nice with
bullies that a lot of people don't know
is that if you do what they dare you you
earn their respect if there was a gift
that summarizes game I think it might be
that you know this came out in 2014 so
it's still eligible for game of the year
you know what it's got my vote I call
upon you Satan Oh goats can't fly my god
i'm going to you shot it I'm gonna break
the game wake up you're dead he's
sleeping on haha oh it's such a
beautiful day hot oh that oh this was
gonna be great that is a jousting
tournament Christian I lost my bail my
parents are gonna go crazy can you help
me find another one a bail like a like
Christian Bale let me see if I can
please the cave dude are you impressed
with this Kings weather oh no man no I
was part of the game whoa you can want
to like a worm wall I think this has
gone really well so far oh yeah this is
terrifying so one is pizza oh my god
that's the best walk it's discovering
like the side step you've looked clazzy
just come out a little bit front flip
they've done such a beautiful job
populating the world it feels like I'm
really there as a microwave we're so go
ahead oh my god snoopy
he automatically flip when you do job Oh
God god that's so like what my camara
way what show do that what sears trying
to roll into this i guess this is it
yeah i don't even know and rely sponder
Ellen on that shot right there that's
that's good it's good [ __ ] garb Laurel
you found a mermaid oh oh you go out
there you kill them kill as many of them
as possible Isaac and take take their
eyes yeah its work them to death oh oh
these guys want to go oh yeah get some
hey girl are you hungry Hey well they
don't have pizzas over there oh sure I
can't wait to have a paid sir hey you
guys want some pizza mmm delicious Peter
where nice that's disgusting here's a
kiss reward you crazy person ooh you
make me sick what an [ __ ] you know
hey Nick slow pants adventurer I heard
you need a microwave you think you could
help me get there safely oh this is a oh
so no hey slow pants haha let's go we'll
save you mix lo pans well get you there
mm-hmm an incredible time too
oh sorry here on the pizza he must be we
must be real close
oh no just a hurt on the corner of
ambition him I think we should exit and
try another goat and see what other
specials are especially which one oh
he's invisible Oh camo he's invisible
hey so you drop's a fish great oh my god
you're such a good patient haha raining
fish hella lien this is good good thanks
for going on this weird journey with me
it was a journey to be remembered I will
never forget this
you